the young kid that like never thought
he'd play Big League Baseball because
big league baseball players are they're
Superstars they're like different than
me and all of a sudden I end up being
one of those people and have this thing
that like only the best of the best get
and it's like still when I see it up
there I'm like this is crazy like yeah I
have a note from my high school coach
threatening to kick me off the team next
to like the sa Young Award like the the
the the disparity those things is like
such a such an interesting contrast you
know bro it's that oh that's so many
feelings that's so much at once dude
yeah what was what was he threatening to
kick you off for do you remember dude I
was I have like four or five of them uh
I got thrown out of a game one time I
was hitting and uh umpire made a b what
I thought was a bad call so I flipped my
bat and I like drew a line in the sand
of like where the ball across the plate
didn't say a word I got tossed and then
of course like you're getting thrown out
of a game not good look for the high
school program I'm not really the most
like social person like a lot of my
social interactions I learned a little
later in life starting in college and
pro ball and stuff I just didn't I I
viewed things differently as a kid I was
kind of different I dressed differently
I thought about different stuff my sense
of humor was different than the normal
kids so I struggled I struggled
socially um in high school you know
Junior High all the way up into high
school I didn't have a a large peer
group um you know I was kind of I was
part of two different groups I was like
part of the athlete group right but I
didn't fit in with them because I was
also a nerd oh yeah and I didn't really
fit in with the Nerds because I was a
jock and so I kind of got pickled
between both of those where I didn't
really have a group that I fit in with
like Clark K almost in a way you know I
mean not not quite as uh as super but
but well you would turn out to be oh
here you are right there yeah Trevor in
this throwback to when the Astros didn't
have to cheat to win that's it that's
sweet oh that's cool dude does that does
that kid look like uh someone that would
fit in so that's actually a uni I would
wear my baseball like pants and uniform
and stuff to school in gr school so I
got I got picked on a lot yeah I I I
remember the the morning um that that
kind of like changed for me I was 17 was
in high school I had gotten up in the
morning to go to the YMCA did my pre
preschool workout came back showered was
looking in the mirror I was like you
know why what what is it about me that
like I don't have friends that people
like don't like me that they bully me
that they pick on me like all this stuff
and I just made the decision that day I
was like I like myself like I'm good in
school I treat people well I'm
hardworking I'm whatever like I like
what I see looking back at me so I'm
going to be okay with that and I'm not g
to I'm going to stop chasing like
approval from other people and as long
as I can be proud of myself like I'm
cool with it and so that gave me the
freedom internally to like have a voice
and when someone would say something to
me I'd fire back and I would feel better
about myself because I felt like I was
defending myself and standing up for
myself and my life got a lot
better uh through the rest of high
school and into college because of that
because I felt like I had a voice and I
was being heard instead of just being
like swatted down all the time when did
you start being good at bait like when
did it start to add up because if you're
doing all those unique pitches like some
of the P like you just have such a cool
like assortment of pitches I almost feel
like yeah somebody's rolling up to the
mound this is from your channel right
here year yeah oh this is back in uh 11
years ago yeah wow you've had your
channel for a long time yeah I started I
think
2011 um to do like you know try to
connect with Baseball fans and like give
some information and then I actually
stopped it for like six or seven years
there from 2013 through maybe 2019 or
2020 I should have kept it going I'd
have a lot more subscribers you got a
great amount of subscribers D 690,000 is
amazing yeah um and did what made you
stop what was the break was you were you
getting busy with baseball no so I
actually got in trouble I would take
video clips from the games make a little
highlight reel I called it weekly whiffs
and I would put it up on YouTube channel
and I did two episodes of it and then
the organization at the time that I was
with at the time was like hey you can't
do that because it was just different no
one was doing that it was right you know
it can be looked at as like you're
trying to embarrass the other hitters or
whatever it had nothing to do with the
hitters I was just trying to entertain
the fans yeah um and so made a couple
more videos after that like the pitch
grips video in 2013 and a couple slow
motion videos here there but um it kind
of in a way it took a little bit of the
fun of like trying to entertain fans out
uh and so I just I was off of it I went
more towards uh Twitter at the time
which is now X but um trying to just
have that like back and forth connection
with fans and grow it that way and that
ended up getting me in a lot of trouble
as well unfortunately people don't like
you to have your own voice a lot of
times yeah you know which is where you
know if you're involved in something
that's bigger like when you have to go
into organizations like major league
sports college sports where there's a
lot of big business interests on the
back end of things they really don't
like a lot of guys to have their own
voices it seems like they don't you're
not really you're allowed to but are you
really allowed to yeah I do see how
someone like me coming up that has these
opinions especially when I would be like
critical of the league like here's an
employee of the league who's being
critical of their boss publicly and like
at the time I was like well this isn't
right and this isn't right and I
disagree with this and blah blah blah
and so I would just say it and then
without considering the opposite
perspective and I think I was a lot more
like I can identify this problem and I'm
just going to say that there's a problem
and blame instead of now what I really
try to do is look and say okay I
identify a problem but what are some
potential Solutions let me present the
solutions that I think and have a
discussion about it instead of just like
hey you're wrong you're wrong do this
this way and whatever so some of that
like Evolution over time growing up and
getting older and learning from past
mistakes starting a business seeing
other perspectives um what about did
your ego did Ego start to build up
because that's one thing I always talk
about a lot in here just like our ego
and what that's like you know because
what was it like when you start to get
like a claim for that if you're kind of
have this social uncomfortability yeah I
um I've always tried to separate ego on
and off the field um I haven't been
great at it but I think having an ego on
the field is super important like when
you walk out there you got to know that
you're the best you have to believe that
you're better than him and him and him
and you got to feel like you're the best
guy out there to be like the true like
competitor you know off the field like
going around telling everybody that
you're better than them and acting like
that's not great right so uh I'm not
naturally like inclined to be
egotistical I because the way I view
things it's never like a static Point
everything is I'm improving or I'm
getting worse it's a it's a fluid
situation and so if I'm either getting
better or getting worse I'm on a journey
just like you're on a journey you have
your struggles and your your successes I
have my struggles and successes I view
myself as like even with every other
person but on the field like when it's
competition time like I am the best
person on the field and if I'm not that
day it's
because like I didn't work hard enough
or I need a better process but like
every time I step on the field I have to
believe that I'm the best person there
and I've had times in my career where I
lost that belief and it was there those
were very dark times performance-wise I
was terrible on the field and I had to
like trick myself and like fake like
fake it in my own mind that I was still
good and then when I started doing that
the results came back but wow um I think
I'm a little predisposed to uh
depression for whatever reason I don't
know if it's something chemical or or
what it is I'm a very like kind of flat
personality I don't have like a ton of
highs and lows so when baseball would go
bad like my mood would go really bad and
I had to find a way to kind of pull
those two things apart and
be regardless if baseball was up or down
I needed to be able to like be okay p in
my life um and would you do to go did
you like would you like if when things
got bad how would you would you booze a
little like how would your world know so
I've never I've never been drunk I've
never done drugs
um wow bro you are you are riding the
[__] world like that's in that's int
it's incredible man it's just I didn't
have friends to invite me to the parties
in high school so I never got started
but um I don't have those like blank
moments or blank hours where
I I I would I would fill those early my
career I'd film going on Twitter for
three hours and Twitter so much fun it
was so much fun and I I had fun with it
yeah but I think me having fun with
people is usually like playful banter
like I'll kind of like throw a little
like jab your way and you throw them
back my way and it's like because it's
jousting match and I like that because
it's witty and it forces me to think and
like it's and I'm having these
conversations with people and I'm like
laughing and joking with them in person
and you get a sense of like I'm not
being serious you can tell very clearly
that I'm not being serious but on
Twitter doesn't come across that way and
especially not even though the person
that you're doing it with may feel that
way may not other people reading it
might get really confused and so I would
banter with a lot of people I think it
got construed negatively by the media I
know it got construed negatively by the
media the larger media as a whole and
then I get this reputation of being
combative and stuff and I was never
doing it from a compatitive standpoint I
understand how it looks that way and how
it came off that way and so those blank
hours where I was just had nothing to do
and I was just like joking with people
and fireing stuff off got you know got
me in trouble um Trump has a great Dave
port I interviewed Donald Trump and he
goes you ever just like he like would
you s was he asking Nick about
proofreading some of his tweets or
something Trump's like yeah you ever
just fire something off and and just go
to bed and just hope it's okay and Trum
was like yeah oh all the time you know
you're like what the hell is going on
yeah half the time it's like damn I
didn't even I never I never would have
thought that that would be interpreted
that way thought twice about it yeah
when did you start to get the
entertainment aspect how did that kind
of come into you do you feel like I
think when I got
comfortable that I was good and that I
had large
like established myself where I was
going to be able to have a career like
early in your career you're just
fighting to stay there and it's like if
you have a bad outing you might not be
there the next day but once you get to a
certain level it's like okay I have some
leeway here I can't be bad forever but
if I have a bad start or two it's not
going to be like I'm gone and so that
gives you a little becomes manageable
yeah and it gives you a little sense of
like settle in you can take a breath you
can be a little bit more comfortable I
like
the banter like we talked about I like
the kind of witty interactions and so I
like figuring out the puzzle of how do I
like take this normally mundane thing
and just put a little twist on it like
make it more entertaining for people and
then yeah starting in like
2020 really after I started the media
company um momentum in 2019 it was like
okay this is an attention economy so in
order for baseball to grow there have to
be clips that are are viral enough to
get to the youth that they see it like
oh baseball's fun right and then I'm
like okay how do I start making some of
these viral Clips well let me study NBA
what goes viral in NBA uh when people do
something like they dunk on someone and
they celebrate it like when LeBron's
flexing on someone like that's
everywhere right when Curry hits a three
but before he the ball's in the bucket
he's already running down the court like
celebrating it because he knows it's in
like that's everywhere so like okay how
do you apply some of that to baseball
it's like all right what can you do in
baseball like are you going to celebrate
a strikeout that'd be comparable to like
flexing on someone when you dunk on them
right are you going to call your shot on
you know the day before the game oh I'm
going to do this with this person are
you GNA have some sort of you know what
does that look like in baseball it's a
good point yeah and so I started getting
the entertainment aspect of it because I
was settled with the performance like I
can entertain or and compete at the same
time right so I can compete and just not
do any entertainment and you're going to
get the same level performance out of me
that you'll get if I'm also doing a
little bit of entertainment um because
I've it's like my base operating level
is intense competition D you're an
interesting dude bro I'm all messed up
my mind's my mind's but you're right
though if you're trying to build this
sport that's what you have those are the
you need some of those moments yeah you
know like the um there's a video out
there and it's a bunch it's it's a vi
just impersonating some of the other
players on your team I think when you're
with the um we're in Pittsburgh the
Indians it was uh shout out Sunshine
Clevenger over there too dude yeah you
know Mike yeah yeah definitely uh been
around Mike man he's a he's such an
entertaining guy yeah um so this is uh
this is a funny story a lot of people
don't know like the followup to this
story so you can see the guys in the
background of this video have rain uh
like tarps on or whatever so it's
raining right so you're in a rigning
game and this is here Cleveland versus
Pittsburgh what year is this this is
2018 Maybe
and as you come up to bat here you keep
kind of impersonating I guess different
players on your team their batting
stances yeah so we had a lot of unique
batting stances this year um and so
always like we get four days off in
between starts as a starting pitcher so
we're in The Dugout just messing around
like we don't have anything to do and so
I was always grabbing something and
trying to impersonate you know mik AIS
Jason Kipnis Raburn Brantley like some
of these guys that had really unique
characteristics and so um at one point I
think it was Mike VI was like hey when
are you g to do that for real like you
won't and I was like I'll do it so I go
and I have this at bat where I you know
do rurn and kipniss and were they all
shocked they were all if you look at the
dug I don't know if there's a view of it
they're all like laughing yeah there
that's Mike right there he's just yeah
seems like such a neat guy huh Kip's
awesome yeah so the followup to this
though is I get I walk in this bat and
so I'm on first base and I'm just this
stupid pitcher like you know running the
bases and whatever and so the catcher
you know obviously the you Pittsburgh
wasn't super like oh they're applauding
again cool Pittsburgh wasn't super like
pleased with that event oh cuz they're
like you guys are joking around out here
yeah so right after that the next pitch
like I take my lead off first and the
catcher catches the ball and like fakes
like he's going to throw it down first
base was nowhere close but I'm not used
to being on base because I suck as a
hitter I'm never on base right so he
goes to throw it down to first and I
freak out and I like dive back and
there's no first basement there and it's
muddy and I stick in the mud and I don't
even make like my hand sticks I don't
even make it back to the base I'm just
laying there by the base looking around
there's no one there the catcher never
threw the ball and I'm covered in mud
yeah and he just like pointed at me and
like threw the ball back to the picture
I'm like all right all right that's good
you got
me that's good I respect
that yeah that's classic that's such a
neat thing about life too how it works
it's like the second you start to get on
your high horse just a little life knock
you down here you go there there's
another really good example that we're
playing the Padres 2021 we're at Dodger
Stadium um and I facing I'm facing uh
Eric Hosmer now I knew hos from he was
in Kansas City when I was with Cleveland
so we played each other a lot so we have
a little bit of a you know a history
like playing each other so the first at
bat I throw him a curveball he like half
swings at it strikes out and I like hit
him with my sword celebration and uh the
next at baty comes up I throw him a
curveball instead of missing it he hits
a rocket right back at my face like it
would have it would have killed me if I
didn't get out of the way I end up like
laying on my back and I'm like laying
that on the M like what just happened
fortunately didn't hit me and he's over
at first base and I start to sit up and
there's actually a picture of me yeah
this is probably it is this yeah that
right and I don't know if this video
clip goes long enough but uh see if I
laugh right here yeah yeah right there
so he's at first base he like hey and I
look over at him and he uh he gave me
the sword back back so I got him the I
got him the pit the theat before and
then he just like got me back and then
let me know about it ttis had a great
one he had a home run off me like put
one one hand over his eye cuz in spring
training I had like thrown in a bat with
one eye closed and then against the
Padre's and then they waited and then
when he got me back he put his eye his
hand over stuff you think it's fun I
love it yeah it's cool actually dude if
people if people would like celebrate on
me all the time I don't care like that's
good for the
game